hey there everyone i live in
pennsylvania which is on the
east coast of the us it would feel odd
to me to give
a bright cheery talk without
acknowledging all that is going on in
the world right now
many of us are feeling sad many of us
are feeling frustrated
many of us are feeling angry and many of
us are hurting
for years we've had a pattern of racial
injustice and systemic racism in the us
for many of us current events have
increased our awareness of this ugly
problem
you must change we must do better
in a global online space like this
chances are good that some of you are
already working to influence change i
applaud you for this
in this space i have a feeling some of
you want to be part of the solution
but aren't sure how it can be so easy to
acknowledge the problem
feel overwhelmed by it and then become
immobilized by that overwhelming feeling
we feel the feelings of sadness and
anger but then don't actually take the
next step to do
something about it it's so easy to let
this happen without even realizing it
in the tech world when we have a large
problem to solve we don't do it all at
once
right we break it down into smaller
tasks or user stories
that can be accomplished in a day or two
when you put all those tasks and user
stories together
you get a full working app so let's do
the same thing here
if you're not already involved part of
the solution i encourage you to pick
one small thing you can do this coming
weekend
and then do it if you're not sure what
you can do i have a list of three things
you can do
i recognize that i'm coming into this
conversation as a white person with
privilege
so the research i've done on how to help
is from that perspective
i'm not saying these are the right
things to do or the best things to do i
just want to give you some practical
examples of small steps that you can
take
right now
so one thing you can do is educate
yourself there are so many ways you can
do this
you can research the history of racism
online
you can go to youtube and other social
media and listen to the stories black
people are sharing
you can learn about microaggressions and
bias and discover how you might be
unintentionally hurting others
one book that's been recommended to me
by a couple of people is how to be an
anti-racist by candy
if you have kids talk with them about
racism and current events
research from harvard university shows
that kids as young as
three embrace racism when exposed to it
it's not too early to talk with your
kids about it it's probably going to be
uncomfortable for you
but it's important embrace race.org has
put together a list of children's books
to help you have these conversations
and finally you can donate if you're in
a position to donate i encourage you to
do
to do so find a cause that reflects your
values
and donate it can be easy to feel
overwhelmed when you start researching
what caused to donate to as there are so
many good organizations
but don't let that sway you from
donating you don't have to find the
perfect cause
find one that is doing good work and
donate to it
if you find another cause later on
that's doing good great things you can
always donate to that cause as well
think about the impact we can make right
now if everyone who is listening
donated just five dollars i know that's
u.s centric but you know donated just a
little bit right
think about if we all donated more there
are many good lists
online right now of organizations to
donate to
so to get you started here are four
organizations that mongodb has been
raising donations for this week
they are code 2040 the bail project
national lawyers guild foundation inc
and national urban link
league inc mongodb has set up a page on
bright funds and is matching funds
up to 250 thousand dollars for for
donations received by june 30th
i've added links to the resources i just
mentioned in a thread on twitter
there's so many other things you can do
you can protest you can sign a petition
you can support a friend who is hurting
you can research politicians for
upcoming elections you can amplify black
voices who are sharing their stories and
ideas for solutions
you can advocate for better hiring and
promotion policies at your company
you can support black owned businesses
or you can get involved in an
organization that is working to
influence change
whatever it is i encourage you to do one
thing this weekend
and then pick something else and do it
next week just don't do nothing
the silence is deafening
okay i don't think there's a smooth way
to transition out of that so i'm not
even going to try
um but let's let's jump into the talk
let's talk about
tables and documents
but first let's talk about ron ron is a
character from the best tv show ever
created
parks and recreation for those of you
who have never watched an episode of
parks and rec
let me tell you a little bit about ron
ron is an old school guy
he's a bit set in his ways he likes his
privacy
and he likes to stay off the grid now in
season 6 episode 14
ron discovers yelp he loves the idea of
being able to review places he's been
however yelp is way too on the grid
for ron so ron uses the internet to look
up the physical mailing addresses of
where he wants to snail mail his reviews
and then he pulls out his big old
typewriter and he starts typing his
reviews
now ron writes some pretty great reviews
here's one of my favorites
dear frozen yogurt you are the celery of
desserts
the ice cream or be nothing
zero stars
now that's a pretty great review but i
see three
three problems with his approach first
up
snail mail is way slower than posting
the review to yelp
where it will be instantly available the
businesses he's reviewing may never open
the review because they may just assume
it's junk mail
and finally no one else will benefit
from the review
i don't know about you but i live for
these kind of reviews online
ron was inspired by yelp and he saw the
value in the technology
but he didn't change his old school
mindset in order to really get the value
out of it
this is what we see sometimes as people
move from tabular databases
to document databases they see the value
of document databases and they're
inspired by the technology
but they bring with them their old
mindsets so they don't get the full
value of document databases
now i don't want this to happen to you i
want to see you be really successful
as you work with document databases
so before we dive in let me introduce
myself my name is lauren shafer
i took a database course in college that
was all about best practices for
relational databases
i began my career at ibm where i spent
eight years
as a software engineer for a lot of that
time
i used db2 toward the end of my time
there
my team started getting flexibility and
what database we wanted to use
so i started trying out different nosql
databases
to be honest i didn't really get the
hype without a doubt no sql databases
were easy to get started using
but i brought with me my relational
database mindset so i kept thinking
about my data in rows and columns
even though i wasn't using rows and
columns anymore
it worked but it wasn't great
i joined mongodb about a year and a half
ago and i've worked through the process
of changing my mindset and how i think
about storing data
i'm so happy i did because it's really
easy to work with data in the apps that
i build now
today i'm going to share with you what
i've learned as i've gone on the journey
of moving from tables to documents
i would love to connect with you on
social you can find me on both
twitter and tick tock with the handle
lauren underscore shafer i don't really
know what i'm doing on tiktok but i'm
having a lot of fun doing it
if you'd like to get a copy of the
slides from today you can get
you can find the link i've pinned it to
the top of my twitter page
all right so today we're going to be
talking about moving from tables to
documents
when i say tables i mean a tabular or
relational database
for example you might have experience
using mysql or
oracle we'll dive into what document
databases are in just a few minutes
so if you're here i'm going to assume
you have experience with relational
databases
and minimal to no experience with
document databases
today we're going to go on a mental
journey from tables to documents
i'm going to kick things off by mapping
the terms and concepts you're familiar
with in tabular databases
to similar terms and concepts in
document databases
then i'll talk about the four major
advantages of document databases
and finally we'll wrap up with three key
ways you need to change your mindset
when you move
from tables to documents so
let's jump right in with terms and
concepts
let's talk about documents
no i'm not talking about word documents
i'm talking about json documents json
stands for javascript
object notation if you've used any of
the c family
programming languages such as c c sharp
go
java javascript php or python
documents will probably feel pretty
comfortable to you
documents typically store information
about one object
as well as any information related to
that object so every document
begins and ends with curly braces
inside of those curly braces are field
value pairs
the great thing about documents is that
they can be incredibly rich
values can be a variety of types
including strings numbers
arrays dates timestamps or even objects
you can have objects within a document
and you'll see what that looks like in
just a moment
when people talk about document
databases they'll often use the term
non-relational but that doesn't mean
document databases don't store
relationships okay that was a double
negative stick with me
document databases store relationships
really well
it's just different than the way
relational databases do
so let's walk through an example of how
you would model the same data in a
relational
tabular database versus a document
database
so let's say we need to store
information about a user named leslie
let's begin with our contact information
in a relational database
we create we will create a table named
users
we can create columns for each piece of
contact information we need to store
so things like her first name last name
cell phone number
and city to ensure we have a unique way
to identify
each row we'll include an id column
so now let's store that same information
in a document
we can create a new document for leslie
where we'll add
field value pairs for each piece of
contact information we need to store
as you can see we have field value pairs
for first name
last name cell and city
we'll use underscore id to uniquely
identify each document
we'll store this document in a
collection that we'll call
users
now that we've stored leslie's contact
information let's store
the coordinates of her current location
when using a relational database we'll
need to split the latitude
and longitude between two columns
document databases support arrays so we
can store the latitude and longitude
together
in a single field we'll call that field
location
we're successfully storing leslie's
contact information and her current
location
so now let's store her hobbies when
using a relational database we could
choose to add
more columns to the users table
however since a single user could have
many hobbies
meaning we need to represent a
one-to-many relationship
we're more likely to create a separate
table just for hobbies
each row in the table will contain
information about one hobby
for one user when we need to retrieve
leslie's hobbies
we'll join the users table and our new
hobbies table together
since document databases support arrays
we can simply add a new field named
hobbies
to our existing document for leslie the
array can contain as many or as few
hobbies as we need
when we need to retrieve likely's
hobbies we don't need to do an expensive
join to bring the data together
we can simply retrieve her document in
the user's collection
now let's say we also need to store
leslie's job history
wrong way so far we've used arrays to
store geolocation data
and a list of strings arrays
boy i jumped all over the place here we
go so just
as we did with hobbies we're likely to
create a separate table
just for job history information each
row in the table will contain
information about one job
for one user so far
we've used arrays to store geolocation
data and a list of strings
arrays can contain values of any type
including objects
so let's create an object for each job
leslie has held
and store those objects in an array
so as you can see we have a job history
field that stores an array
inside of that array we have an object
for when she was the deputy director
an object for when she was a city
councilor and an object for when she was
director of the national park services
midwest branch
so now that we've decided how we'll
store information about our users in
both tables and documents
let's store information about ron
ron will have almost all of the same
information as leslie
however ron does his best to stay off
the grid so he will not be storing his
location in the system
let's begin by examining how we would
store ron's information in the same
tables that we used for leslie's
when using a relational database we are
required to input a value for every cell
in the table
so we'll represent ron's lack of
location data
with null the problem with using null is
that it's unclear whether the data does
not exist
or if the data is just unknown so many
people discourage the use of null
in document databases we have the option
of representing ron's lack of location
data in two ways
we can omit the location field from the
document or we can set location to null
best practices suggest that we omit the
location field just to save space
so you can choose if you want omitted
fields and fields set to null
to represent different things in your
applications
so ron has some hobbies and some job
history so we'll add his information to
those tables
and we can add that information as well
to his document
so right now the structure of ron's
document looks pretty similar to
leslie's
so let's say we're feeling pretty good
about our data models and decide to
launch our apps using them
then we discover we need to store
information about a new user
her name is lauren burhaug she's a
fourth grade student who ron teaches
about government
we need to store a lot of the same
information about lauren as we did with
leslie and ron
her first name last name city and
hobbies
however lauren doesn't have a cell phone
location data or job history
we also discover hey requirements change
we need to store a new piece of
information
for school all right so let's begin by
storing lauren's information in the
tables as they already exist
we can create a new document for lauren
and include the data we have for her in
it
so now let's talk about how to store
information about lauren's school
in our tables we've got two options
we can choose to add a column to the
existing users table
or we could create a whole new table
named schools
let's say we choose to add a column
named school to the users table
depending on our access rights to the
database
we may need to talk to the dba and
convince them to add the column
maybe we have to do a little begging to
get our dba to add the column
maybe we have to do a little bribing
maybe we bring our dba their favorite
donut
or maybe we bring our manager along to
pressure the dba
into agreeing if our dba agrees
the database will likely need to be
taken down the school column will need
to be added
no values will be stored in every row in
the user's table where a user does not
have a school
and then the database will need to be
brought back up it's totally do
doable but it can be a little painful
so now let's talk about how to store
lauren's school in documents
we can simply add a new field named
school to lauren's document
we do not need to make any modifications
to leslie's document
or ron's document when we add the new
school field to lauren's document
document databases have a flexible
schema so every document in a collection
does not need to have the same fields
now for those of you with years of
experience using relational databases
you might be starting to panic at the
idea of a flexible schema
i know i started panic a little i when i
was introduced to the idea
but don't panic this flexibility can be
hugely valuable as your application's
requirements
evolve and change also some document
databases provide schema validation
so you can lock down your schema as much
or as little as you'd like
when you're ready
so now that we're starting to get the
idea of how tables and documents
are similar and different let's do some
explicit term mapping
so on the left side of the screen you'll
see tabular or relational database terms
and on the right side of the screen
you'll see document database terms
so first up we saw this a bit in our
earlier example
a row maps to a document
or depending on how you've normalized
your data rows from multiple tables
could map to a single document
a column maps roughly to a field
now in a relational database groups of
rows are stored in tables
in a document database groups of
documents are stored in collections
so tables map to collections
the next few terms will probably feel
pretty comfortable to those of you with
relational database backgrounds
as the terminology is basically the same
between the two
just like you store groups of tables in
a relational database
you store groups of collections in a
document database
indexes are fairly similar between the
two indexes help speed up your read
queries
views are pretty similar in both
there are a few different ways to handle
joins in a document database
the general recommendation is that if
you have related information
that you would put in a separate table
in a relational database
you should embed that information in a
single document when working in a
document database
the rule of thumb is data that is
accessed together
should be stored together let me say
that again
data that is accessed together should be
stored together
so if you'll be frequently accessing
information together
that you would have put in separate
tables you should likely just
embed it in a document depending on the
document database you're using
there are other options for joins as
well
some databases support references
between the documents
similar to how you would use a foreign
key
some databases also have special
operations to support a left outer join
now these options for joins get specific
to the database you're using so i'm not
going to go any deeper into it here
today
all right finally let's talk about acid
transactions
transactions group database operations
together so they either all succeed
or none succeed if you did some research
online about relational databases versus
document databases before coming here
today
you probably saw something about
document databases not supporting
transactions as a major drawback
if you care about data integrity and
really who doesn't
that's a pretty scary sounding drawback
some document databases support acid
transactions
while others do not in relational
databases we call these
multi-record acid transactions
in document databases we call these
multi-document asset transactions
however when you model your data for
document databases
you'll find that most of the time you
don't actually need to use
a transaction i'll explain why that is
at the end of this presentation
so don't get freaked out if you're
looking at drawbacks of document
databases
and you see no transactions listed
some document databases support
transactions
some don't but chances are good that
either way
you won't actually need them
all right so to wrap up this section i
created this term mapping summary for
you
it's way too much information for you to
read now but you can take a screenshot
and tweet it or you can print it and
hang it up at your desk
whatever you need to do but before we go
on
i want you to internalize the first
three term mappings because they'll help
you out through the rest of this
presentation
so a row maps to a document
a column maps to a field and a table
maps to a collection
with water break okay so now that we
have an understanding of
the terms and concepts let's talk about
the four major advantages
of document databases
let's jump back to ron for a moment ron
loves his typewriter
and unless you convince him otherwise
there is no way he's going to change his
mindset
maybe that's you maybe you've been
really successful with relational
databases
if you're comfortable with them they
aren't always the easiest but you've
learned how to get the job done
so let's answer the question is it worth
changing your mindset
from tables to documents i'm going to
walk you through four advantages to
using document databases
and these are in no particular order so
let's begin by talking about scaling
let's say ron has an app where he sells
the chairs he makes in his workshop
ron's using a relational database behind
the scenes
when one of ron's chairs is nominated
for an award
from the indiana fine woodworking
association
orders start pouring in he needs to
scale his database
now typically relational databases will
scale vertically
when his database becomes too big for
its server
he has to migrate it to a larger server
when ron's chair appears in bluesh
magazine
his chairs go viral and he needs to
migrate to an
even larger server there are a few key
problems with vertical scaling
large servers tend to be more expensive
than two smaller servers with the same
total capacity
large servers may not even be available
due to cost limitations
cloud provider limitations or just
straight up technology limitations
migrating to a larger server may require
application downtime
all right let's take another example
let's say tom has an app for his
restaurant
tom bistro he uses a document database
behind the scenes
after a feature in the pawnee journal
his restaurant surges in popularity and
he needs more space for his database
since tom is using a document database
he has the flexibility
to scale horizontally through sharding
sharding is a method for distributing
data across multiple servers
when his database exceeds the capacity
of its current server
he can begin sharding and split it over
two servers
when the shelter in place orders hit
pawnee and everyone has to order food
online
tom can continue to add more servers the
advantage is that these new servers
don't need to be big expensive machines
they can be cheaper commodity hardware
plus
no downtime is required so with document
databases you can scale cheaper
at the size your database grows you can
scale horizontally
your queries will typically be faster
with document databases
let's examine why even in our simple
example we worked through earlier where
we modeled leslie
leslie's data in both tables and
documents
we saw that your information was spread
across three different tables
whenever we want a query for leslie's
information we'll need to join those
three tables back together
so in these three small tables the join
is going to be very fast
however as the tables grow and our
queries become more complex
joining tables together starts to become
very expensive
so recall our rule of thumb when
modeling data in document databases
data that is accessed together should be
stored together
when you follow this rule of thumb most
queries will not require you to join any
data together
so back to our example if we want to
retrieve leslie's information from a
document database
we can simply query for a single
document in the user's collection
as a result our query will be very fast
as our collections grow larger we don't
have to worry about our queries slowing
down
as long as we are using indexes and
continue following our rule of thumb
i'll say it again data that is accessed
together should be stored together
all right requirements change
it's a regular part of the software
development life cycle
sometimes we're lucky the changes are
simple and require
only a few tweaks to the user interface
but sometimes changes go all the way
down to the database
so let's think back to our earlier
example where we needed to update our
database to store information about
lauren's
school to add a new school column in our
relational database
we're going to have to alter the users
table
executing the alter table command could
take a couple of hours depending on how
much data is in the table
the performance of our application can
be decreased while the table is being
altered
and we may need to schedule down time
for our application
now let's examine how we can do
something similar in document databases
when our requirements change and we need
to begin storing the name of a user
school in a user document
we can simply begin doing so we can
choose if and when to update existing
documents in the collection
if we'd implemented schema validation we
would have the option of applying the
validation to
all inserts and updates or only to
insert some updates to documents that
already meet the schema requirements
we would also have the choice of
throwing an error or a warning if a
validation rule is violated
with document databases you can easily
change the shape of your data
as your app evolves
all right finally you can program faster
now to be honest with you this advantage
is one of the biggest surprises to me
i figured that it didn't matter what you
used as your backend database the code
that interacts with it would be
basically the same
i was wrong documents mapped to data
structures in most popular programming
languages
this sounds like such a simple thing but
it makes a huge
difference when you're writing code a
friend encouraged me to test this out
so i did i implemented the code to
retrieve and update user profile
information
now my code has some simplifications in
it to enable me to focus
on the interactions with the database
rather than the user interface
i also limited the user profile
information to just contact information
and hobbies so let's walk through my
implementation
i used my sql for my relational database
and mongodb
as my document database i wrote the code
in python
but don't worry if you're not familiar
with python i'll walk you through it
step by step
the concepts will be applicable no
matter what your programming language of
choice is
and once again i've moved in the wrong
direction okay
so before i show you the code let's do a
quick refresh of the data we're going to
retrieve and update
on the left we have a table for users
and a table for
hobbies on the right oh my goodness
i'm click happy today
on the right we have a document for our
user that contains both
contact information and
all right hopefully you guys got to see
that
so let's begin with the typical top of
the file stuff
we'll import what we need connect the
database
and declare our variables i'm going to
simplify things
by hard coding the user id of the user
whose profile we will be retrieving
rather than pulling it dynamically from
the front end code
now if we look at the mongodb code it's
basically the same thing
importing connecting and setting the
user id variable
now that we have our database
connections ready let's use them to
retrieve our user profile information
we'll store the profile information in a
python dictionary
dictionaries are a common data structure
in python and provide an easy way to
work with your data
so let's begin by implementing the code
for mysql
since the user profile information is
spread across the users table
and the hobbies table we'll need to join
them in our query
so we'll say select everything from the
users table
left join hobbies we can use prepared
statements to ensure our data stays safe
we'll set the values in our prepared
statement execute the query
and fetch our result
now because we joined the users and the
hobbies table we have a result for each
hobby
this user has so to retrieve all the
hobbies
we need to iterate the cursor we'll
append
each hobby to a new hobbies array and
then add the hobbies array to our user
dictionary
now let's implement that same
functionality from mongodb
since we stored all of the user profile
information in the user document
we don't need to do any joins we can
simply retrieve a single document
in our collection so here's where that
big advantage
that documents mapped to data structures
and most popular programming languages
comes in comes in i don't have to do any
work to get my data into an easy to work
with python dictionary
i get all the results in a python
dictionary automatically
and i don't need to manipulate the
results i'm done
now our user dictionaries are now pretty
similar in both pieces of code so here
you're looking at those dictionaries
the one exception is how we're storing
our location data but this is a
pretty minor difference so
now that we've retrieved the user's
profile information we'd likely send
that information
up the stack to the front-end ui code
let's take a look at her profile
information in our app
let's say she discovers she needs to
update her profile information
so the front-end ui code would send that
updated information in a python
dictionary
back down to the python files we've been
writing
so let's simulate leslie upton your
profile information
we're just going to manually update the
python dictionary ourselves
for both mysql and mongodb
and these updates are basically the same
with once again just that exception of
how the location data is being stored
now that our user dictionary is updated
let's push the updated information
to our databases so let's begin with
mysql
first up we need to update the
information that is stored in the users
table
so we'll say update users set first name
equal to this string last name equal
this string
cell equals this string all the way
through
and we'll set the values of all those
strings
is this complicated no not really
is this error prone yep
you have to make sure you get every
string in just the right spot
now to be honest with you i didn't unit
test this code i know
bad developer um so it's possible that i
made a mistake without realizing it
this is a pretty uh simple example so i
probably got it right
but sql queries can get really long so
you can imagine this getting much more
complicated
next we need to update our hobbies for
simplicity we'll delete
any existing hobbies in the hobbies
table for this user
and then we'll insert the new hobbies
into the hobbies table
all right now let's update the user
profile information in mongodb
since the user's profile information is
stored in a single document
we only have to do a single update so
once again we're going to benefit from
documents mapping to data structures in
most popular programming languages
we can send our user python dictionary
when we call
update one and that's significantly
simplifies our code
in this example we wrote 27 lines of
code to interact with our data in mysql
and two lines of code to interact with
our data in mongodb
while fewer lines of code is not always
indicative of better code
in this case we can probably agree that
fewer lines of code will likely lead to
easier maintenance
and fewer bugs now this example was
relatively simple with small queries
imagine how much bigger the difference
would be for larger more complex queries
so documents mapping to data structures
in most popular programming languages
can be a huge advantage in terms of time
to write
debug and maintain code
so is it worth changing your mindset and
learning how to work with a document
database
i mean i think so with the document
you can scale cheaper query faster
pivot easier and program faster
all right so now let's move into our
final section and this is our shortest
section
let's talk about three key ways to
change your mindset
as you move from tables to documents
people who pick up a document database
and try to use it as a relational
database
are the ones who typically struggle and
fail
you can't keep doing things in the same
way so let's talk about three key ways
to change your mindset
first up embrace document diversity
let's think back to when we modeled
documents for leslie ron and lauren
we saw that not all documents in a
collection need to have the same fields
now for those of us with relational
database backgrounds this is going to
feel
uncomfortable and probably a little odd
at first
i promise it will be okay embrace
document diversity
it gives us so much flexibility and
power to model our data
in fact there's a schema design pattern
that specifically focuses on documents
not having the same fields it's called
the polymorphic pattern
we use the polymorphic pattern when
documents in a collection are of similar
but not identical structures
let's take a look at an example that
builds on the polymorphic pattern
so let's say we decided to keep a list
of each user's social
media followers inside of each user
document
lord and leslie don't have very many
followers so we could easily list their
followers
in their documents for example lauren's
document
might look something like this
at the bottom of her document we can see
a list of her followers brandon
wesley and sierra this approach would
likely work for most of our users
however since ron built a chair that
appeared in the very popular
blush magazine ron has millions of
followers
if we try to list all of his followers
in his user document
it may exceed a document size limit
so the question arises do we want to
optimize our schema design for the
typical use case
where a user has a few hundred followers
or the outlier use case
where a user has millions of followers
we can actually utilize the outlier
schema design pattern to solve this
problem
the outlier pattern allows us to model
our data for the typical use case
but still handle outlier use cases
we can begin modeling ron's document
just like lauren's
and include a list of followers when we
begin to approach the document size
limit
we can add a new has extras
field to ron's document and this field
can actually be named anything we'd like
then we can create a new document where
we will store the rest of ron's
followers
if ron continues to gain more followers
we can actually create another overflow
document for him
the great thing about the outlier
pattern is that we are optimizing for
the typical use case
but we have the flexibility to handle
outliers
so embrace document diversity resist the
urge to force
all of your documents to have identical
structures just because it's what you've
always done
second way to change your mindset data
that is accessed together
should be stored together i know you've
heard me say it all day to day
thing is you've probably heard over and
over that you should normalize your data
okay why is that well historically there
are a couple different reasons for this
one of those is that when relational
databases became popular
disk space was extremely expensive
financially it made sense to reduce data
duplication
and save disk space as you can see from
this chart
and you probably know from buying flash
drives the price of storage has
dramatically decreased
our phones tablets laptops and flash
drives have more storage capacity today
than they did even five to ten years ago
for a fraction of the cost
when was the last time you deleted a
photo i mean i can't even remember when
i did
i keep even the really horribly
unflattering photos
and i currently back up all my photos
external hard drives and multiple cloud
services
storage is so cheap
storage has become so cheap that we've
actually seen a shift in the cost of
software development
30 to 40 years ago storage was a huge
cost in software development
and developers were relatively cheap
today the costs have flipped
storage is a small cost of software
development and developers are expensive
instead of optimizing for storage we
need to optimize for developers time
and productivity as a developer i like
this shift right like i want to be able
to focus
on implementing business logic and
iterate quickly
those are the things that matter to the
business and move developers careers
forward
i don't want to be dragged down by the
data storage specifics
so think back to our earlier example
where i coded retrieving and updating a
user's profile information
even in that simple example i was able
to write fewer lines of code
and move quicker when i used a document
database
so leverage embedding consider
how you can use objects
arrays and arrays of objects
to store your data together resist the
temptation to break up your data
data that is accessed together should be
stored together
if you end up repeating data in your
database that's okay
especially if you won't be updating it
very often
all right last way to change your
mindset tread carefully with
transactions
some document databases support asset
while others don't but here's the thing
if you're modeling your data for the
document model you're probably not going
to need a transaction
in fact relying on transactions is a bad
design smell
okay why well it's actually built on our
first two points in this section
first not all documents need to have the
same fields
perhaps you're breaking up data between
multiple collections because it's not
all of identical structure
if that's the only reason you've broken
the data up you can probably just put it
back together in a single collection
second data that is accessed together
should be stored together
if you're following this principle you
won't need to use transactions
some use cases call for transactions
most do not
if you find yourself frequently using
transactions take a look at your data
model
and consider if you need to restructure
it
alright so to summarize the three key
ways to change your mindset
embrace document diversity data that is
accessed together should be stored
together
and tread carefully with trend with
transactions
all right let's wrap up this
presentation so today we went on a
mental journey from tables to documents
we began by mapping terms and concepts
from tables to documents
the three that are most important are
those first three
rows mapped to documents columns mapped
to fields
and tables mapped to collections
then we talked about the four major
advantages of documents
you can scale cheaper because you can
scale horizontally
you can query faster because you aren't
having to do expensive joins to bring
your data together
you can pivot easier because you have a
flexible schema
and finally you can program faster
because documents map to objects
in most popular programming languages
and then we wrap things up with the
three key ways you need to change your
mindset
so first embrace document diversity not
all of your documents need to be the
same shape
and that's perfectly okay
second data that is accessed together
should be stored together
third tread carefully with transactions
relying on transactions when you're
using a document database
is a bad design smell so if i had to sum
up this presentation in one idea
i would say this don't be around
wisconsin i mean in this particular case
because ron is awake
amazing in so many other ways but don't
be wrong
swanson change your mindset and get the
full value of document databases
at the end of this presentation i've
included a list of additional resources
the top resource listed here is a blog
series that i wrote that has content
very similar to what i presented today
but it's specific to mongodb
if later you want to reference the
material i covered that's a great place
to start
one of the best ways to learn new
technology is by trying it out
mongodb atlas is a fully managed
document database service
it's got a perpetually free tier that is
great for learning if you'd like to try
it out
if you hop back a slide i have a link to
a quick start blog series that will walk
you through trying it out
as a reminder if you'd like to get a
copy of my slides you can check out my
twitter page
i'm lauren underscore shafer
alright that is all i have for you today
thank you so much for coming
i hope you enjoy trying out document
databases thank you